that was our stunning guest and our dear
friend of the show michelle buteau and
she is now in the new rom-com marry me
you did a lot of ad labang um like they
would do takes and then give you the
floor is that true yes you know if you
hire a comedian then you should use them
for what they're good for and good at
and so
i love when i can go off script and just
you know just go ham my favorite is
trying to break the person i'm in a
scene with and so yeah i got jennifer a
couple of times okay tell me because she
i mean she seems like the funnest most
amazing woman i could not be on her feet
anymore i am obsessed with j.lo
but she seems like put together like
what's it like when she breaks
i mean you know it's so this is what i
love about doing comedy because no
matter
what lines you have in your head what
to-do list you have on your mind
whatever you have to do it's just pure
joy that comes over your body sort of
like a sneeze you can't control it or
like a fart you can't control it but you
know you feel better afterwards
but the poor i'm so sorry what's wrong
with me i haven't left the house in
three years so the point is um yeah it
was really fun and you could tell you
know she is um she's busy she's got a
lot to do she is a businesswoman she is
running companies she's taking care of
people she knows what camera angles
could like get our shot faster to get us
home for dinner with the family i like
efficiency
you guys also are both the mother of
twins yes so what what was that like to
talk to someone who also has been
through an extraordinary rare unique
journey yeah you know um it was really
special i mean the main thing for me was
to respect jennifer's um space so i
really kind of
acted like i didn't know that she had
twins and i was um sleep training the
twins while i was filming this movie oh
my gosh came to set one night uh one
morning exactly what day was it and one
eye was open i think and she's like are
you okay and i'm sleep training my girl
boy twins and she said i have girl boy
twins i say you do i didn't know that
j.lo but i knew it i wanted to be like
how was max and emmy but i was just like
really tummy and so um yeah we shared um
tips and tricks and so she had a lot of
tricks which is really nice yeah okay so
your book survival of the thickest is
now out on paperback
but please tell us what else just
happened with your phenomenal book oh my
goodness well netflix has acquired the
rights of the book and so we're turning
it into a tv show eight episodes
yeah
it is a dream come true
yeah it's a dream come true
i cannot wait for this show i like i
need it now
um okay
is it true that because i started a
magazine and you had a magazine when you
were young
called head over heels oh my goodness
you do your research
i do we do good producers and we care so
much right so tell me about head over
heels your magazine when you were a
young girl i created a magazine because
i didn't even know what community was
but i knew that i craved for it and uh
and i was only eight years old and i
started a magazine called head over
heels and the logo was horrible it was
like a shoe with a severed head in it i
don't know
what you know what can you say and i
would put it in all the neighbor's
mailboxes and i thought i did a bang-up
job but the neighbors asked my parents
if i would stop leaving stuff in their
mailbox
and then also you had a talk show oh my
god okay so i used to get um girls
together for saturday morning because i
wasn't allowed to watch cartoons really
why my mom wanted me to be productive
and so i i know now um i work in
television but um
it was a cabbage patch uh and pound
puppy club it was very hoda and kathy
lee but with like fourth graders about
their pound puppies and their couch
batch dolls and you had to give stories
and recipes and what outfits you liked
you know what
i'm i i like this [ __ ] i know that's
like it's a lot
um as a last uh question any advice for
me as a talk show host
no i think you're doing all the things
that i want to see in a talk show host
because um
people already know you and you're
already america's sweetheart but there's
this depth and realness and quest for um
you know
knowledge and you're excited and you
only want people to be their best
because you want to be your best thank
you for your service thoughts and
prayers
[Applause]
that was not what i was expecting i
thought there was like a pound puppy
joke coming
[Music]